tous les matins c'est une ambulance
adapté qui amène fabian une chambre au
centre de réadaptation ylang ylang
[Musique]
depuis bientôt un an
fabian passe toutes ses journées dans ce
centre spécialisé et la partie doit
quitter roule tout seul c'est
passionnant là c'est à moi de juger il y
a un an et demi fabian a été victime
d'un accident de travail
[Musique]
un an plus tôt nous l'avions filmer pour
le journal télévisé dans son entreprise
de recyclage des métaux à saint paul
vous êtes un ancien de production
sermoyer messieurs natale et fabian a
été happé par une machine est très
grièvement blessé touché à la moelle
épinière
il est aujourd'hui tétraplégique ses
jambes sont totalement paralysé ses bras
partiellement les soins consiste donc à
récupérer le maximum de mobilité
d'autonomie à lesparre et ça commence ce
matin en ergothérapie avec wendy bonjour
ça c'est le plateau torture le plateau
il va servir à un refermer un peu la
main puisqu'il a des difficultés à
attraper les objets puisque ça me ses
doigts sont comment dire ça m'a aidé
ouverte
donc là on va chercher à venir refermer
il attire mais l'espagne ce qu'au début
on nous téléphone mais gagne pas face à
ma mère profite pas pour but de pousser
il connaît ou s'appelle the way de à la
télé ou imagine toi tout ce qu'ils font
franchement c'est reprendre sa vie à
zéro
et s'ils restent pour le plus petit
qu'un 1 et éviter de la lumière est pas
sympa de la peau avec le fauteuil
c'est pour ça moi aujourd'hui mais plus
parce qu'ils jouent ça me sort est
aujourd'hui m'a bien récupérer avec les
séances c'est ça il est fier de ça parce
qu'ils convoitent il ya cinq ans quand
tu viens je ballon et envoie un ballon
aux lillois qui il était lié à rouen ne
sont pas pas voilà alors du coup la
moneda du matériel adapté justement donc
là une planche s'il est fait maison avec
des clous dedans pour justement pouvoir
stabiliser de l'oignon comme s'appelant
day là il faut la patience mais on va à
la foire pourtant depuis la rive à moi
ça fait un moment la malade cette vie le
tc a accepté j'ai où les données
recueillies la colère les grilles b ou
avance pocher avons été court mais tu es
comme les coyotes marie bct quoi doit-on
passer à droite à gauche mais non mes
potes on fait les choses
mais voilà mais pour le temps savoir
l'aviation
voilà
dernier exercice ce matin le passage de
porc donc la lune va mais tu as dû sur
deux roues qui demande beaucoup d'
équilibre beaucoup de fausses de la
sérénité aussi est peut être folie il
sert à faire le coq mais aussi a
vraiment pas de trop car tout ça c'est
bon tu ne bosses moins d'un mois c'est
[Rires]
70 ya là maintenant ça tu peux voir est
parti c'est là le fait que lève comme ça
on passe ainsi par la porte au quai de
la fosse et sébastien
[Musique]
ça va là
avec carlos le kinésithérapeute fabian
va maintenant travailler le transfert on
pense face avant de permettre de se
moquer du fauteuil d'aller sur les lits
sont bien plus salée encore encore en
cours mais bon elle a le prochain la
prochaine étape s'est couché couche et
voilà qu'elle est allé dormir et ça
c'est pas trop facile aussi les pages de
faire un nom 18 son petit est mort
d'homme dans la jambe mais bon ça aussi
pareil au départ c'était mission
impossible tu vois monsieur une chambre
vous allez bien avec la docteure chamba
enfin bien se prépare à une nouvelle
aventure
installez-vous priorité le permis de
conduire ouais parce que c'est vrai
qu'il n'a pas il n'y a pas grand chose
ici il ya des véhicules adaptés mais pas
suffisamment à votre état de santé
dans deux jours tous les deux vont
prendre l'avion pour rejoindre dans le
nord de la france un centre de
rééducation disposant d'une auto école
spécialisée à quoi allez on y va
d'action mais ce centre jacques alvès
juste en face de manière superbe avec un
beau ciel bleu d'un cancer cela passe
par l'obtention du permis de conduire
donc c'est sur ce genre de véhicule on
peut tout avoir
c'est une boule au volant les commandes
au volant
et ça ça n'existe pas actuellement la
réunion non non non ça il n'y a pas ce
genre de structure c'est pour ça que
voilà on part ensemble pour et passer le
permis et prendre toutes ces
informations afin de s'essayer de monter
ça ici sur lie la ville de la réole et
servait montfort je crois pas que ça
vient donc il la santé au moins
super c'est parti pour le sport alors
sarah fred super on va se placer ici
souffle bien quand tu tires verts entend
porter sont là en fait on remue ce qu'au
niveau des écoles et des biceps
au début tu es vraiment faible fait
tenir teignait juste le faire
nous sommes forts s'il revient qui peut
tout cas ni franchement même de la
propulsion du fauteuil mais ça fait quoi
c'est mon mari mais tu es sur mon fils
voilà nous propulse à nous et aller
signer son qe papa ici elle vient aussi
parce que combibloc ali comme la licence
est pas se taire c'est un marathon
franchement c'est quoi tout ce qui s'est
fait à bord a fait un peu moins 1000
bosses plus qu'avant et pourtant voir
médium et accueillant mais là et avancer
des métiers ça comme rien du tout mais
n'aura c'est ma robe et régis et un
maroc
c'est un marathon avoir attendu fouet
[Musique]